all right joining me now Raymond a royal
Fox News contributor Raymond all right
you went out and talked to some caucus
goers were the Ians typically reticent
well they were a bit reticent and we
went to a a little icy spot that has
really become a staple in presidential
politics we embedded here in Iowa watch
we're here at the Pizza Ranch where
guess who the latest Hired Hand is and I
thought I'd talk to some of the caucus
[Music]
goers
are you voting in the caucus this year
uh we are we just was talking over uh
dinner and we're going to vote and who
are you voting for for Donald Trump why
because I think he has his act together
I think he's a non-politician so to say
in that he's got the love of the country
and the people's best interest what's
the biggest issue driving your vote
economy second second uh the Border who
will you be voting for Donald Trump sure
why
uh have you seen the way the country's
going I I did notice exactly if you want
food on your table you want lower bills
you want lower everything you don't vote
for Joe Biden all I know is Trump did
good for me and right now we're
struggling so I'm bringing back what did
good for our family we see Nikki Haley
and Ronda Santa saying if you vote for
Donald Trump it's going to be all about
Donald Trump and his court cases does
that dissuade you at all I think that's
crazy I think he he has the country's
best interest and the love of the people
and I'm
sorry Republicans a name only they are
rhinos if you would put it that way and
I'm looking forward to four plus more
years what we had in 2016 through 20
biggest thing is
economy I feel that me and my husband
are both hardworking people we work
full-time I'm a nurse he's in Heating
and Cooling and we just can't get ahead
right now and I feel that Trump only did
good things for our country and it's
only plummeted since probably between
Haley and um the SES what's the main
issue driving your cus boat
um right now I I'm not exactly sure
probably uh just inflation and wages and
things like that hey Ray grab those
chicken tenders and those potato wedges
okay I'll get
them
okay here they are
[Music]
awesome I'm uncertain who I'm going to C
this for right now tonight who are you
weighing well I don't know maybe dis sis
been Governor I think he can I think
he's been exposed to enough and
hopefully he's got a good uh sense of
what's going on in the world you going
to call this yeah I'm going Trump why
you you supporting the
president because anything driving it I
mean is it a you want to change from
Biden or we really pisses people off in
Iowa is
the what do you call all them people in
cahoots the
swab boy I tell you I got a taser
remember in music man they used to talk
about that chip on the shoulder
sensibility the Ians still have that
these are not people you can't easily
are people they will tell you exactly
what they a lot for candidates to cut
through most of them told me though they
are voting for the Trump record what he
gave them before that they want back
again that seems to be driving a lot of
this what was the pay for that slinging
the chicken from the uh ice they have
some amazing chicken at the Pizza Ranch
has the best fried chicken in in uh we
were there with Santorum right we were
what was that Rick Santorum got on top
of a salad bar with with a bullhorn to
make his final pitch just before he won
this yeah this and poor Rick Santorum
actually won the the caucuses and he
didn't find out till several weeks later
sometime later but this is the place to
go for all these presidential candidates
and VI ramaswami has visited more of
these than on any other candidate this
season this is where the people live is
that a a score the underscore music was
that from the old heaw what was that
that was gunm smoke that don't tell
anybody that was a real winner oh r that
was we'll see how the evening well see
we're going to try to go into one of the
caucuses perhaps hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else